Marvel Studios is switching up a lot of
what they have been doing in Phase 4 and
Phase 5 of the MCU and we're about to
see some pretty big changes come to
Phase 5 and the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and not just for
Phase 5 and Phase 6 but what Marvel
Studios is doing is going to infect the
future of the MCU even after Avengers
Secret Wars this is going to go into
phase S phase 8 and Beyond you might
have heard that Marvel Studios has
reportedly considered cancelling many
projects lately this is true and they
have also been firing people internally
as well now this can all sound pretty
bad on the surface and of course it's
unfortunate for those people involved
with the projects that are going to be
cancelled and those being let go for
Marvel Studios however the reason that
all of this change is happening at
Marvel Studios is so they can become
better we'll dive deep into it but it's
been recently revealed that Kevin fee
essentially hears everything and he
listens he listens listens to the
criticism he listens to the criticism of
the critics his peers the people who
work at Marvel who work at Disney but
most importantly he listens to the fans
because after all the fans are what
Drive everything and it's also been made
pretty clear that Kevin fogy and Marvel
Studios use hype to their advantage
however at the same time I do want to
note that Kevin fogy does listen to
criticism from the fans however he
doesn't let them control what Marvel
Studios does Kevin fige has plans and he
follows through on those plans however
of course with each project that comes
with each Disney Plus show and each
Marvel movie he grows and he learns from
the past recently there was a book that
was released that a lot of people are
talking about right now it's called MCU
the reign of Marvel Studios the authors
of this book who come from the industry
interviewed over a hundred different
people who are all involved with the MCU
the book is being talked about a lot
right now and we're going to go over
many different things that are in that
book throughout the course of a few
different videos but it's being talked
about so much right now because it tells
us the juicy inside stuff about Marvel
Studios kind of some of the drama that
goes down and one of the authors even
stated this is the book Marvel doesn't
want you to read it's packed with a lot
of inside information that we didn't
really know until this book was
published because of all the interviews
they did and the information and
knowledge that they gained I bring this
up in this video because they talk about
Kevin fige and they actually praise
Kevin feige in pretty great detail they
have been some fans out there recently
stating that Kevin fige did a great job
before but isn't doing such a good job
now and somebody new should come in but
I don't agree with that I think for
those who haven't been enjoying the MCU
too much recently it can definitely
bounce back under the reign of Kevin
feige because he has been there from the
very beginning with Marvel since X-Men
in 2000 he was an associate producer on
that film and of course he built the MCU
don't get me wrong he wasn't the only
person but he's been with Marvel for a
very long time and of course he's been
the president of Marvel Studios for a
long time now as well but most
importantly he is a true fan I think
recently he might have had his hands
really full with all of the Disney Plus
shows working those in with the movies
had to be hard and he didn't have as
much time as he normally had to dedicate
to each project because there were so
many projects which is why they are
making some of these changes to the MCU
now this is why they're cancelling some
of the shows and their focus is Shifting
many insiders have stated recently that
Marvel Studios is going to be cutting
back on some Disney Plus shows and Kevin
fige and Bob Iger the man running Disney
right now even stated this as well they
said they're going to release fewer
Disney Plus shows and the rate at which
they release them is also going to
decrease and like I mentioned you
probably heard of some shows being
completely Rewritten or cancelled
recently the authors who wrote this book
say that they've heard the Wonderman
Series has been scrapped however some
insiders say differently we'll have to
wait and see on that but one big thing
is the Daredevil series they are
completely rebooting what they have had
already written it's starting over from
scratch the show is not cancelled
however they did not like what they had
Kevin foggy was not okay with it the
authors of the book noted that Marvel
Studios doesn't exactly alter their
plans because of the fan reactions a
good point of this is Marvel Studios
continuing to make Captain Marvel 2 or
the Marvels even though a lot of fans
have spoken out and said that they don't
really like the first Captain Marvel
film and they don't really like Brie
Larson clearly Marvel Studios has seen
all these f talk about this they've
heard this but they're not changing
their course for what they had planned
one of the authors Joanna Robinson
States they aren't listening Kevin fagy
has plans and he follows through on them
when he can but she also credits him for
being flexible if they don't work out
they State the recent Daredevil Born
Again news was an example of Kevin fige
course correcting basically Kevin feige
looked at what they had for Daredevil
born again he wasn't okay with it and
said start over we're going to do this
right it's going to be a good show these
characters are going to be great we're
doing it right the same thing goes for
these other shows that are being
Rewritten or cancelled and the reason
that these people are being fired and
Marvel Studios is really beginning to
clean up shop we'll talk about that more
in just a bit but first big thank you to
fume for sponsoring this video fume is a
GameChanger for a lot of people in
turning bad habits into good habits a
lot of people struggle with these bad
habits but fume looks at these in a
different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
help them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,00 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trf nume.com and use code Cosmic
to save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today that's trfu m.com and use
code Cosmic to save an additional 10%
off your order today now as far as
firings go over at Marvel Studios yes
they have fired quite a bit of people
recently and recently they have
Rewritten or have started to rewrite a
lot of scripts recently Marvel has fired
writers and directors why because
they're going to get it right they're
not satisfied with what they've been
doing they hear fans trust me they hear
fans they know that there are a lot of
fans out there that aren't really
satisfied so what are they doing working
really hard to make sure the rest of
phase five and phase six is going to be
phenomenal and they started that with
two of their biggest upcoming movies
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars the writers for both of
those movies who already wrote for
previous Marvel films were fired Jeff
lovess who wrote Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania was originally supposed to
write and was hired by Marvel Studios to
write Avengers the King Dynasty and
Michael Waldren who wrote Loki season 1
and wrote Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness was hired to write
Avengers Secret Wars unfortunately we
heard that they were let go the reason
most likely being the so-called failures
of Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
and Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness I wouldn't really call them
failures but Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania didn't do too well in the
box office and a lot of fans did
complain about quantam Mania and
Multiverse of Madness however I think
they're fine films but since they didn't
do incredibly well at the normal
standard that Marvel has they're
bringing in new writers Destin Daniel
keton who directed shangi and the legend
of the 10 Rings was also supposed to
direct Avengers King Dynasty but
according to some recent reports he is
no longer going to direct that film
Marvel is making a ton of changes but
it's all going to lead up to a soft
reboot of the MCU and from there Marvel
studios's focus is entirely going to
shift right now Marvel Studios is in a
weird spot where we kind of have some of
the original Avengers but they're
introducing a lot of new characters
however once the soft reboot happens the
MCU is going to completely change
because from there they're going to
focus on yes new characters but new
characters that everybody knows and
typically loves characters like the
X-Men so Cyclops Professor Xavier storm
Jean gray Magneto Nightcrawler Kitty
Pride Etc all of the X-Men that people
love then of course the Fantastic Four
and then groups like The Midnight Suns
going into the supernatural side of the
MCU which Kevin feige said that they are
going to fully Embrace then they are
still going to have characters like
Spider-Man who of course everybody knows
and loves though so right now Marvel
Studios is kind of in a limbo phase and
don't get me wrong they have an amazing
plan for Phase 5 and phase six of the
MCU and Avengers the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars and Deadpool 3 should be
fantastic but it is kind of going to be
the end of an era for the MCU it's kind
of going to be the end of The Avengers
era and from there it's going to dive
into the groups that I just mentioned so
Marvel Studios is really changing their
plans not only internally and
structurally with the releases of how
they do the Disney Plus shows and their
movies but also how they focus each
project so we have a lot to look forward
to from now until Avengers Secret Wars
but then we have a lot to look forward
to after as well and it's great to know
that Marvel Studios really is trying to
adapt and change and get better so that
fans can enjoy the content more and out
of everything that they have up and
cominging including the things past
phase six like the X-Men and the
midnight Suns Etc let us know what you
are most excited for in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items some DC
items as well the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof